this is what i've always argued for
if if i'm an agent and i represent an
nfl quarterback let's say i i represent
derek carr
derek carr is not a top 10 quarterback
but i don't want him to price himself
out
because if you say hey i want to have i
want to get 45 million dollars a year
there should be a soft spot there where
where nobody gets embarrassed
and and and it's you're going to have
max contracts but there should be
contracts that allow a quarterback to
kind of
fall into
a safe a safe spot
that you're going to get 25 million
dollars a year
four years 25 million dollars like if
you did that with if mitchell trubisky
could say to the bears he could hit the
wayback machine and just go you know
what why don't you pay me an average of
25 million dollars a year
went to the playoffs to the years that
he was there as a starter he put up
decent numbers
but if you're going to go i want
seven years 200 million dollars then i'm
not interested so it feels like it's
either all or nothing
and it feels like what you have with
deandre ayton
four years 133 doesn't sound bad
because kevin durant got four for 190.
like okay is kevin durant worth 50
million dollars more yes
but deandre ayton got the max not the
super max
and that's where i think you can keep
players on teams and certainly your
quarterbacks because it feels like
everybody the next guy up
kyler murray lamar jackson what are you
going to pay me
but even look back at baker mayfield if
i said to baker mayfield look don't over
play your hand
you're starting quarterback you're
making money off the field you've got a
good team
but agents don't do that